tudo bem com vocês comigo está ótimo
afinal estou aqui realizando um grande
sonho
pensa em uma pessoa que assiste ted pelo
menos duas vezes por semana faz mais ou
menos 54 muito prazer essa sou eu por
isso que eu estou tão animada por estar
aqui muito bem
eu gostaria que levantasse a mão quem
conhece alguém e se chama maria
obrigado muito obrigado
maria é o nome feminino mais popular do
brasil desde 1930
segundo o ibge maria minha avó
glória maria minha tia maria de fátima
minha sogra maria torres minha
professora e tantas outras marias que eu
conheci na minha vida
tem também o felipe
meu primo ele adora dizer que vai levar
dona maria pra passear no final de
semana se referindo a esposa dele mas o
nome dela kelly e tenha claudina minha
mãe não leva maria no nome mas foi
criada para ser maria e eu
marcelle porto que foi criada para ser o
que eu quisesse - maria
eu cresci acreditando que maria era um
simples dona de casa fui uma criança
muito inteligente uma adolescente com
espírito de liderança muito marcado na
fase adulta desenvolvi um pensamento
bastante masculino muito comum as
meninas que nasceram na minha geração
uma geração de mulheres que é dona de
seus direitos deveres e decisões
eu tinha um objetivo muito bem definido
queria estudar ganhar dinheiro e ser
independente
por muito tempo eu fui intuitivo
impossível impaciente e tinha um
comportamento
lamento que beirava arrogância
tudo o que eu não sabia procurava
prender
trabalhei muito duro desde muito cedo e
o novo sempre me motivou
e sempre foi assim até o dia que eu abri
minha empresa e eu administradora com
especialização em finanças que tinha
trabalhado um pouco como vendedor um
pouco na área financeiro um pouco como
consultora e de todo o pouco que eu
fazia o dinheiro que eu ganhava guardava
para viajar
eu sempre fui uma turista de carteirinha
desde os 13 anos ganhei autonomia e
liberdade dos meus pais que me
autorizavam a viajar para casa de amigos
na região dos lagos na década de 90 o
sonho de boa parte do carioca era ter
casa de praia na região dos lagos
e foi aí que o meu sonho também começou
a nascer quando eu comecei a trabalhar
o salário era pouco mas mesmo assim eu
dava um jeitinho e viajava primeiro pra
casa dos amigos depois para algumas
pousadas aqui mesmo no estado do rio de
janeiro o salário aumentou um pouquinho
comecei a me planejar e organizar e
viajar de férias para outros estados do
brasil
conheci hotéis resorts e outros meios de
hospedagem minha faculdade terminou eu
pinal mente eu parei de investir o seu
dinheiro nos estudos e pude dar um passo
um pouco maior
comecei a viajar para o exterior
primeiro guay depois nova york a áfrica
do sul e hoje já conheço 14 países por
ter toda essa vivência no turismo
eu imaginei que tinha total capacidade
para empreender nesse ramo
eu abri um rosto ou que é uma espécie de
pousada com espaços compartilhados mas
não foi qualquer rosto e mãos
eu criei o bis five rosto house primeiro
hostel temático de cerveja do rio de
janeiro
comecei a ganhar a admiração dos meus
amigos da minha família por ter me
tornado empresária
comecei a ganhar notoriedade das pessoas
nos ambientes de negócio que eu
freqüentava
mas quando eu olhava no espelho
sabe o que eu via uma grande maioria no
rosto eu eu precisava lavar passar
cozinhar cuidar de uma casa cuidar de
pessoas que eu não conhecia abrir uma
empresa quem diria fez nascer minha
maria meu primeiro ano de empresa foi
muito difícil cheio de fracasso de
conflito de desespero eu fiz negócio com
amigos e perdi muitas amizades
isso me doeu muito viver rodeada de
amigos sempre teve grande importância
para mim eu fiquei desequilibrado
emocionalmente e eu quebrei vive no
fundo do poço mais profundo que eu já
freqüentei a mão que me resgatou desse
lugar foi a mesma que me levou ao altar
pouco tempo depois sim eu casei e junto
com meu marido transformei o rosto no
nosso lar o desafio de morar dentro da
empresa é bem grande
assim como desafio dos primeiros meses
de um casamento quando dois mundos
totalmente diferente se unem com muita
fé e amor fomos equilibrando a casa o
casamento ea empresa
criamos nosso próprio jeito de receber
mapeamos processos ajustamos cursos
fizemos excelentes parcerias e forçamos
o conceito da marca logo depois eu
ganhei uma premiação a nível nacional
reconhecendo meu talento empreendedor
parecia que meu inconsciente precisava
que alguém dissesse
que aquele caminho que eu estava se
lindo era o correto
por mais que o rosto eu fosse bem aqui
dentro eu continuava sentindo estava
apenas cuidando de uma casa
foi aí que eu percebi que eu passei a
vida escondendo a minha força feminina e
não sabia lidar com ela
precisei buscar a história das lutas e
conquistas femininas para compreender
que passei a vida me espelhando no
comportamento masculino e esqueci de
perceber o quanto a trajetória das
mulheres havia me permitido chegar num
lugar que eu estava
tive a sorte de ter longas tardes de
conversa com a minha avó maria ela viveu
92 anos muito bem vividos
nasceu na paraíba em 1925 em uma época
que a mulher sequer tinha direito ao
voto
quando ficou moça começou a gostar de um
rapaz mas a sua mãe escolheu outro homem
para que ela se casasse
ele era músico e resolveu vir com ela e
três filhos pequenos para o rio de
janeiro tentar uma vida melhor pegar um
carona em um caminhão numa viagem que
durou sete dias foram morar em uma
favela da zona sul
ela tinha um filho por ano no total teve
10 ele cantando nas ruas não conseguia
dinheiro para sustentar tantas bocas ela
começou a lavar roupa pra fora pra dar o
que comer a sua grande família
ela ficou viúva antes dos 40
ela já era avó antes dos 40
antes dos 40 ela casou novamente dessa
vez roncar aquela mava mais jovem
solteiro e sem filhos
esse cara foi considerado um louco né
esse louco era meu avô pai do meu pai
ele era pedreiro
e se orgulhava de contar que participou
da construção de brasília
afinal foi com esse dinheiro que ele
conseguiu comprar um terreno na baixada
fluminense onde criou toda essa grande
família de filhos netos bisnetos e até
tataranetos
eles passaram por muitas crises no nosso
país conheceram a ditadura a pobreza até
a fome mas conquistaram o que mais
queriam teto e comida na mesa
eu passei a olhar com tanto orgulho o
detalhe das das mulheres da história das
mulheres da minha família
passei a entender o tempo que elas
viviam à minha mãe por exemplo nasceu na
década de 60 quando as primeiras pílulas
contraceptivas foram criadas
ele tem um ela casou 17 anos numa época
que o marido podia devolver a esposa
caso ela não fosse mais virgem
interrompeu os estudos para criar os
filhos
quando estava quase fazendo 30 anos
percebeu que não tinha experiência e
muito menos formação decidiu estudar fez
um concurso público e passou conquistou
sua independência
minha total admiração minha tia irmã da
minha mãe
desafiado o meu avô que era o tipo de
homem que achava que a mulher foi feita
pra cuidar de casa
ela foi a primeira mulher da minha
família ter um diploma de ensino médio
ea trabalhar em uma loja de
departamentos com carteira assinada
minha sogra educou meu marido a dividir
responsabilidades domésticas de uma casa
minha cunhada se separou de um casamento
que não a fazia feliz e casou com o meu
irmão
alguns anos mais jovem que ela
em uma demonstração de coragem liberdade
e muito amor
cada passo dado na história dessas
mulheres
representou uma conquista à frente do
tempo que elas viviam
eu demorei tanto tempo pra entender isso
demorei tanto tempo pra conectar a força
das minhas marias
a mulher que eu me tornei aprendi que
precisamos desenvolver a força do saber
feminino para construir uma sociedade
melhor
afinal o futuro que queremos está nas
bases do nosso passado eo futuro que eu
quero estar nos saberes de maria da
minha maria na sua maioria a você aí que
se chama maria a quem se conectou com
alguma maria maria que cuida maria que
educa maria que transforma maría que
entrou em di maría tão forte ao mesmo
tempo tão sensível
maria que nasce com a bênção de gerar um
novo ser e é especialista em doar amor
muito obrigada